hola a todos cómo están jason soy ian
gracias por vernos y estamos aquí con
nuestros suscriptores
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y una experiencia religiosa algo
profundo algo profundo cuando tenía
nueve años vi un ángel de verdad si
jubilee presenta reunimos a siete
cristianos amo soy cristiano soy
cristiano soy cristiano soy cristiano
soy cristiano yo soy cristiano soy
cristiano uno de ellos miente si el
grupo descubre quién está mintiendo se
repartirán el premio es
si el mentiroso se queda en lo ella se
ganarán todo el premio es el impostor
[Música]
muy bien aquí vamos sí soy aún una buena
pregunta si no se me ocurrió otra ya
había pensado en decir eso cuando me
presentara porque sabía que si no lo
decía dirían que no soy cristiana oyente
y cuéntame a una experiencia religiosa
alguna experiencia religiosa y algo
profundo algo profundo cuando tenía
nueve años vi a un ángel de verdad y te
sentiste fue bastante genial fue
espeluznante primero en ese momento
había mucha calma fue muy impresionante
en la biblia cuando describen a los
ángeles es una imagen que da mucho miedo
no creo que alguien se alegre de ver a
un ser humano desfigurado por completo
el juego una experiencia muy similar
cuando mi padre falleció de verdad así
es extraño
primero ronda a ronda rápida fue
aterradora no sabía qué preguntar ni
siquiera que decir
hay mucha presión tranquilo no estamos
viendo a la primera persona en quien
confío fue brandon él y yo estábamos
hablando y le dije muy bien amigo tú y
yo juntos hasta el final votaremos por
la misma persona
[Música]
hay un empate entre dos personas
romy y grace
así que tienen que votar de nuevo
[Música]
i
cielos no lo creo gracias tienes amigos
lo arruinaron estoy decepcionado porque
siento que se basaron en mi aspecto
general yo no había dicho nada y ya me
habían expulsado crees estaba justo a mi
lado y estaba algo asustada decía cosas
como espero que no piense que soy
malvada y eso y yo pensé bien no es
grace tampoco era romy pero sabía que no
era grady a preguntarte segunda ronda
iglesia es amigable con la comunidad
el jefe si de hecho hay dos pastores y
uno es una lesbiana birracial por qué
elegiste una iglesia no confesional
porque nací en ella mi padre es un
gestor
alguien más hp yo sé
tienes un hp el hijo del pasto si no lo
había escuchado seis suelen ser los
chicos malos de tu colegio hay ciertos
términos que creo que todos conocemos
supuse que su falta de conocimiento
significaba que no era cristiano e
intentaba captar las cosas mientras las
decíamos java cuánto tiempo ha sido
luterano toda mi vida así crecí en
euskadi a minnesota y gran parte del
pueblo era la iglesia fue bautizado allí
vas a una iglesia y si voy a una en
riverside acabo de empezar a ir allí
hace unos dos meses porque crecí yendo a
una iglesia más estricta por eso me
aleje pero volví qué quieres decir con
una iglesia estricta crecí siendo
mormona
[Risas]
lumar mi propio camino y averiguar lo
que funcionaba mejor para mí estoy de
acuerdo yo me he alejado de la iglesia
porque es difícil encontrar a una
iglesia baptista que acepte a la
comunidad queer por eso deje de ir a
estar buscando algo activamente la mitad
de mi respuesta me di cuenta que no debí
decir eso todos los demás decían que sí
que iban a la iglesia y que yo era el
único que dice
que no y ahí pensé que quizá no debí
decir eso cuando me cambié de iglesia la
gente me estaba juzgando y lo estaban
haciendo bastante me estaban condenando
segunda ronda disculpen tengo mala
escritura mencionó que no había ido a la
iglesia más de tres años así que sentí
que su historia sobre ser un hijo de
pastor y sobre entrar y salir de su fe
puede ser una coartada
quería escuchar a todos los demás hablar
no paraba de hacer preguntas como si no
quisiera hablar de su experiencia
lo siento gracias
así que tercera ronda una buena pregunta
sería cómo encontraste tu fe está bien
yo era un ateo antes de ser cristiano
era un ateo empedernido y estaba muy
deprimido agobiado por mi propia vida
diría yo y luego al entrar en una vida
en la que te llenas de amor de otras
personas y de dios en especial lo que me
hizo volver a la iglesia lo que me
motivó fue que tuve una ruptura muy mala
y hubo un momento en que estaba en el
trabajo y vi a un niño morir yo
trabajaba en emergencias y al ver al
niño morir y a la familia pasar amor
esas emociones me dije vaya tiene que
haber algo que me haga sentir pleno y me
haga sentir completo creo que tiene que
haber este poder superior si no el ego
se apodera de nosotros y dios me permite
darme cuenta de que hay algo más que yo
como artista creo que hay mensajes que
me llegan y que debo comunicar a través
de mi arte donde niña me gustaba mucho
la iglesia era
seguro tuve una vida hogareña difícil y
allí sentía que podía ser yo misma y
después me di cuenta de que era gay
por eso me aleje pero regresé a ella
como adulta ha sido una lucha pero es
algo que quiero tener en mi vida
soy hija de un pastor nació la religión
mis padres se divorciaron en un verano y
así me fui alejando porque el divorcio
en la iglesia era escandaloso fue
difícil pero siento que toda esa
situación solidificó mi relación supe
siempre que había alguien ahí para mi
tercero romper mi iglesia estaba ahí
para mí no tengo idea de quién elegiré
haré lo que hagas tú si ella es hija del
pastor sabe cómo responder conoce el
papel a la perfección en un momento ella
mencionó su postura sobre el sexo
prematrimonial para mí eso fue una
alerta
bien gracias a dios nos vemos luego
harías una pregunta y si entonces así
que estábamos hablando de cómo te
expresas a través del arte quiero que lo
expliques con más detalle cuando
menciono el arte como su forma de todo
yo estaba como realmente no tiene
sentido bueno una cosa que me gusta de
la iglesia es que me hace cantar bien y
mientras crecía a mis mejores recuerdos
de la iglesia eran cantados en el coro y
cuando me mudé aquí una de las cosas más
difíciles fue no tener una iglesia creo
que a través de mi voz de los signos soy
parte de algo más grande ya que hablamos
de esto muchas de las personas que van a
mi iglesia han pasado por esto para mí
han sido heridos por la iglesia
quizá una canción como house y la fas o
cuánto nos ama
en el pasado era importante para
nosotros pero la iglesia nos lastimó y
eso lo hace más difícil mientras crecía
escuchaba una canción de mi iglesia
mormona se llama
las familias pueden estar juntas para
siempre y luego del divorcio de mis
padres ni siquiera la puedo escuchar ni
siquiera puedo mirar la letra de esa
canción sí sí y qué hay de ti cómo fue
tu experiencia al mudarte al otro lado
del país y agresión a un pueblo de 500
personas y la iglesia lo era todo y
quería también salir de allí y comenzar
la búsqueda de una iglesia que acepte la
comunidad del g20 que sean buenas
personas que tenga buenos salmones eso
busco y por eso cuando escuché sobre la
tuya fue como espero minuto pero sí que
me sorprenderé si ustedes mienten
[Música]
dios gracias levanten la mano si creen
que el impostor sigue aquí
si las luces se ponen verdes expulsaron
al mentiroso si las luces se vuelven
rojas el mentiroso sigue allí y ustedes
pierden mi mente se ponen en rojo porque
me voy a sentir muy tonto es una locura
3 2 1
hola soy el impostor oye me sentí un
poco traicionado así sentía que andrew
era un cristiano estaba seguro a bueno
sorprendió porque andrew habla como
muchos pastores jóvenes en mi iglesia
porque soy gay si alguien más es gay
quiero que seamos amigos entonces me
dije es mi amigo no voy a votar por él
porque de verdad le creo y me equivoqué
no pasa nada
oh dios mío me convertí en un ateo justo
después de que me bauticé
creo que cuando me bauticé pensé que
algo mágico sucedería y nada sucedió
nada cambió todavía me sentía realmente
odiado por mi iglesia tengas cosas que
nos llevaron a la iglesia ya la religión
fueron cosas que encontré por mi cuenta
sin la religión por experiencia personal
creo que es importante como
experimentamos la religión yo creo que
muchas veces el cristianismo es algo
monotemático donde todos hacen lo mismo
si se predica la palabra evangélica eso
suele significar algo pero no suele
representar a todos los cristianos
incluso la palabra cristiano apenas
representa a los cristianos me siento
aliviado de que esto haya terminado pero
también siento mucho amor y compasión de
este grupo de personas me preocupaba
cómo iba a ir esto pero me di cuenta de
que todos ellos son muy buenas personas
todos son increíbles tengo una pregunta
para ti hubo algún momento en tu vida en
el que buscaras a alguien y resultará
que estabas completamente equivocada
creo que es cada dos meses cada año creo
que todos estaríamos mucho mejor si fue
un 12 respecto a ello si siempre estamos
haciendo suposiciones y dejando que
nuestros inusuales estados predispuesto
hasta que algo te despierta que sales de
ti mismo y te preguntas por qué me
siento así él pensó que este programa
nos ayudaría a explorar eso y como
nuestros prejuicios pueden entrar en
conflicto con la verdad estradense para
otros episodios llegarán pronto am y
síganos en instagram tenemos mucho
contenido y por lo demás comenten abajo
cuéntenos que les ha parecido y nos
vemos pronto adiós chicos
jubilee